[Music]
you
until an arsenic aluminum selenium
hydrogen oxygen nitrogen really a
McNichol Virginia neptunium germanium
iron americium ruthenium uranium who
ropm selenium lutetium vanadium
lanthanum osmium nasty radium mold
cracked and indium gallium
iodine is or even silly Italian yttrium
ytterbium actinium rubidium forums of
lithium niobium iridium Thomson silicon
silver - Mariam bismuth bromine lithium
beryllium fairy
[Music]
holmium am haften urban phosphorus
francine fluorine terbium manganese
Mercury molybdenum magnesium dysprosium
and scandium and cerium see Jim Lane
president baca plutonium palladium
promethium potassium polonium tantalum
technetium titanium tellurium
cadmium passing chromium sulfur
californium a fermion berkelium
mendelevium einsteinium nobelium argon
Krypton neon radon xenon zinc radium
chlorine carbon cobalt copper tungsten
tin sodium
these are the only ones of which the
news has come to Harvard and there may
be many others but they haven't been
discovered
[Music]